[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend nichts worauf man
stolz sein könnte das ist das Urteil der
Ukraine in Bezug auf die
Abschlusserklärung des G20-Gipfels der
ja gestern in Indien zu Ende gegangen
ist der russische Angriffskrieg wurde
darin zwar thematisiert aber nicht klar
verurteilt heute dann die nächste
Enttäuschung für das Land denn die
deutsche Außenministerin hatte zwar
warme und verständnisvolle Worte im
Gepäck aber keine Taurus
marschflowkörper warum diese vierte
Reise in die Ukraine seit Kriegsbeginn
heute überhaupt dann notwendig war auch
darüber habe ich mit Annalena baerbock
gesprochen zuvor Henna Hebestreit
pünktlich auf die Minute und dann noch
mit frisch gewinnerten Handgriffen auf
die ukrainische Eisenbahn ist Verlass
selbst im Krieg die
bundesaußenministerin wird es gefreut
haben ihr Ziel ohne Verdruss erreicht zu
haben besonders gesprächig ist sie
trotzdem nicht ein knapper Gruß dann
erklären uns die Lokführer wie Sie
solche Staatsgäste pannenfrei ans Ziel
bringen
diese Züge fahren meistens ohne Haltung
mit voller Fahrt und so wichtigen Gäste
die Hilfe bringen sondern doch pünktlich
ankommen
es ist schon Annalena baerbocks vierte
kriegsvisite in gepanzerten Autos geht
es durch Kiew der erste Termin ist ihr
eine Herzensangelegenheit sie besucht
eine Einrichtung wo man sich um Kinder
kümmert die nach Russland verschleppt
wurden und jetzt traumatisiert nach
Hause gekommen sind
in kindesworten war
helft uns damit Putin diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnt
und ja meine Botschaft da aber meine
Botschaft auch jeden Tag in den über 560
Tagen im letzten Jahr ist
wir helfen euch nicht nur sondern wir
stehen an eurer Seite eine Botschaft die
sie immer wieder bemüht und die doch
Risse bekommt als sie die von der
Ukraine erwarteten Marschflugkörper
Taurus wegen immer noch offener
Sicherheitsfragen nicht zusagt
ihr wisst doch ihr werdet sie liefern es
ist nur eine Frage der Zeit
und ich verstehe nicht warum wir hier
Zeit verschwenden wir hätten schon mehr
erreicht und mehr Leben von ukrainischen
Soldaten und Zivilisten gerettet wenn
wir Taurus bereits hätten
ahnt haben dass sie hier nicht punkten
kann aber den Verteidigern in der
Ukraine gehen langsam die Waffen aus
es gibt noch viel zu tun und die
Ausrüstung hält nicht ewig dauernd geht
etwas kaputt es wird zerstört und muss
repariert werden die modernen Waffen
sind besser und können mehr als die
alten sowjetischen aber sie leiden auch
neue Waffen konnte sie heute nicht
versprechen aber der Ukraine immerhin
Mut machen sie ihren langen Weg in die
EU nicht alleine gehen zu lassen
deutschland will die Ukraine weiter
wirtschaftlich humanitär und auch
militärisch unterstützen Taurus
Marschflugkörper um die die Ukraine seit
vier Monaten bittet gab es aber auch
heute nicht weil noch Fragen geklärt
werden müssen so die deutsche
Außenministerin und damit einen schönen
guten Abend Anna-Lena baerbock nach Kiew
schönen guten Abend welche Fragen müssen
denn noch geklärt werden
Marschflugkörper das sind
Flugkörper mit sehr großer Reichweite
die sind dringend nötig das habe ich
hier auch noch mal wieder deutlich
beschrieben bekommen um den riesigen
minengürtel den das russische Regime
gelegt hat um den Osten der Ukraine
komplett abzuschirmen wo sah seit
anderthalb Jahren keine humanitäre Hilfe
reinkommt um die Menschen dort hinter zu
befreien das sind hoch moderne
Waffensysteme und deswegen muss da jede
Einzelheit Stimmen und da sind wir
gerade mit Hochdruck dran aber die Frage
war ja was wollen Sie denn noch für
Antworten quasi von der Ukraine in Bezug
auf diese Taurus marschflow-körper hören
der Kanzler zögert weil er sagt ja oder
sein Argument ist ja die Reichweite es
könnte bis nach Russland gehen es ist
aber ja auch so dass man diese
Reichweite begrenzen kann man kann sie
ja programmieren wieso machen sie das
nicht
das stimmt die Fragen haben sich ja auch
die Briten und auch die Franzosen
gestellt unsere Systeme sind technisch
nochmal anders und wie bei unseren
anderen Lieferungen bei ihres Tee zum
Beispiel den Luftverteidigungssystem was
auch eins der hochmodernsten auf dieser
Welt ist wo wir dann aber gesehen haben
wie hoch effizient es ist aber natürlich
nicht wirken kann wenn man dafür nicht
ausreichend Munition hat mussten alle
Fragen geklärt sein und wie bei den
anderen Lieferungen die jetzt so
wahnsinnig große Hilfe leisten ihres Tee
auch dem Patriot ist es für uns wichtig
dass wir Dinge nicht nur versprechen
sondern dass wir dann auch wirklich
liefern können und wie gesagt da sind
wir gerade mittendrin das heißt es geht
tatsächlich immer noch um die Reichweite
sie haben die Briten und die Franzosen
gerade angesprochen die haben so eine
Begrenzung wohl eingebaut und Verträge
mit der Ukraine geschlossen und das Land
hält sich auch daran haben sie kein
Vertrauen
doch natürlich haben wir vertrauen der
sonst würden wir die Ukraine ja nicht
seit anderthalb Jahren bei ihrem Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung unterstützen
angesichts der Brutalität dieses Krieges
ist es aus meiner Sicht nur wichtig dass
man Dinge da nicht zu sehr simplifiziert
dass man Dinge über einen Kamm schert
die nicht über einen kam geschoren
werden können das Taurus System ist eben
noch mal ein anderes System als die
anderen Systeme und deswegen habe ich
eben deutlich gemacht dass es für uns
wichtig ist alle Dinge ausreichend zu
klären ihr werdet es sowieso machen hat
heute ihr Amtskollege Kollegah gesagt
würden Sie denn wenn sie könnten jetzt
liefern oder stehen sie da dieses Mal
wirklich an der Seite von Olaf Scholz
der ja immer etwas länger braucht bis er
dann tatsächlich liefert
ich verstehe dass die Frage in
unterschiedlicher Richtung gestellt wird
aber ich habe dazu alles gesagt und vor
allen Dingen ist mir wichtig dass wir
eben nicht nur die Frage von der
Verteidigung sehen ich war ja heute hier
auch um den eu-prozess mit zu
unterstützen der so wahnsinnig wichtig
ist für die Zukunft der Ukraine und auch
die Frage wie wir Menschen in den
besetzten Gebieten die wir ja unter
anderem mit diesem Material hoffentlich
endlich irgendwann befreien können wie
wir die erreichen können mit humanitärer
Hilfe wie gesagt seit anderthalb Jahren
hat die Menschen in der Ostukraine kein
Hilfskonvoi erreicht seit anderthalb
Jahren sind Menschen dort gefangen
gehalten ich habe gerade
Familienangehörige getroffen meine
20-Jährige die gesagt hat mein Vater
wurde verschleppt vor zwei Jahren die
letzten zwei Geburtstage konnte er nicht
mit mir feiern sie trug sein Sakko
als glauben daran dass er irgendwann mal
wiederkommen wird und darum geht es eben
auch und deswegen stellen wir uns in
schwierigen militärischen Fragen aber
deswegen hören wir nicht auf auch alles
diplomatische alles humanitäre dafür zu
tun dass die vielen Tausenden von
Menschen seitdem wir seit so langer Zeit
nicht wissen was mit ihnen eigentlich
passiert hoffentlich irgendwann erreicht
werden können EU-Beitritt auch wichtig
für die Ukraine Energieversorgung auch
das war eines ihrer Themen auch wichtig
aber sie wissen dass man damit natürlich
und das scheint ja dann doch immer noch
auch das Ziel Deutschlands oder aber
auch der Europäischen Union zu sein den
Krieg zu gewinnen dafür braucht es
Waffen was bringt denn so eine Reise wie
heute außer einem etwas bei der
Pressekonferenz ungehaltenen
ukrainischen Außenminister und einer
vielleicht an der ein oder anderen
Stelle etwas genervten deutschen
Außenministerin
klar demonstrativ gezeigt die
Solidarität die sich dann auf Fotos
wieder spiegelt aber was noch
also man sollte Pressekonferenzen nicht
als Maßstab für die Zusammenarbeit sehen
gerade weil wir uns seit diesen
anderthalb Jahren so gut kennen ist es
wichtig auch für die Ukraine und ich
treffe hier so viele Menschen an einem
Tag die sagen wie wichtig ist für sie
ist dass wir hier sind dass sich das
Umspannwerk sehe was letzten Winter so
hart getroffen worden ist wo es Blackout
hier mitten in der Hauptstadt gibt wo
ich mit daran wirken kann dass eben vor
dem Winter dieses Umstand wann Werk so
geschützt wird dass nicht wieder bewusst
Strom Verteilzentren angegriffen werden
in der Hoffnung damit die
Wasserversorgung die Wärmeversorgung zu
zerstören ich bin hier um weitere
Unterstützung auf den Weg zu bringen bei
der Energieversorgung wie wir z.B das
ukrainische
Elektrizitätsnetz noch besser anders
europäische ankoppeln können und bei der
Frage wie wir die Menschen in der
Ostukraine über das Internationale
Komitee des Roten Kreuzes erreichen
können
Verständnis für die nachfragen zum
Militär dürfen wir nicht vergessen es
geht jeden Tag um das er überleben von
Millionen von Menschen in diesem Land
und erst recht jetzt wenn wir wieder vor
einem Herbst und vor einem bitterkalten
Winter stehen sagt Anna-Lena bärburg die
heute in die Ukraine gereist ist um
unter anderem den Außenminister aber
auch den Präsidenten zu treffen vielen
Dank fürs Gespräch
danke ebenso alles Gute
ja Menschen ziehen also für ihr Land in
den Krieg und wenn sie wieder nach Hause
kommen sind sie ja in der Regel nicht
mehr dieselben gezeichnet von inneren
und oder äußeren Wunden ist es für viele
schwer wieder in das normale Leben in
den Alltag zurückzukehren erst recht
wenn der Krieg im eigenen Land ja noch
gar nicht vorbei ist was
Kriegsversehrten Soldatinnen und
Soldaten hilft ist der Austausch die
Sichtbarkeit die Gemeinschaft und für
all das stehen die erstmals in
Deutschland stattfindenden Invictus
Games sie sind ein internationales
sportfestival bei dem der Wettkampf also
nicht an erster Stelle steht torgebode
hat einen ukrainischen Sportler
begleitet
der Kampf an der Front ist für Ivan aus
harson vorbei und der Kampf zurück ins
Leben fällt leichter wenn man nicht
alleine ist Ivan hat seine Frau
Katharina seine Mutter wieder und die
Kinder Nastja und Maria die leben seit
anderthalb Jahren in Hamburg hier in
Düsseldorf ist die Familie seit langer
Zeit endlich wieder vereint und für Ivan
ist es das erste Mal überhaupt dass er
die Ukraine verlassen hat
ich fühle mich einfach sehr gut endlich
habe ich meine Familie wieder ich bin
einfach nur glücklich
Düsseldorf ist auch ein sehr schöner Ort
ich fühle mich hier sehr wohl und
geborgen
spontane Applaus von Passanten für den
Veteranen die waren erfüllt das mit
Stolz
und neben seiner Familie hat die
Wahnsinn seine Kameraden er selbst tritt
beim Bogenschießen an und beim Schwimmen
bei den Invictus Games in Düsseldorf
steht da sportliche Wettkampf aber nicht
unbedingt im Vordergrund es geht um die
Gemeinschaft den Zusammenhalt das Gefühl
dass man mit seinem Schicksal nicht
alleine ist alle Soldatinnen und
Soldaten hier wurden im Kampf zum Teil
schwer verwundet oder sind traumatisiert
der Sport hilft ihm
meine Verwandten haben sich für mich
geschämt ich war sehr aggressiv ich
wusste nicht mehr was ich machen soll
aber der Sport hilft es funktioniert
wirklich und auch bei den Jungs
wichtig für viele Soldaten weil es eine
Möglichkeit der Rehabilitation ist Sport
zu treiben und in der Ukraine haben wir
viele Verletzte eine so große Zahl von
verletzten Soldaten
die entdecktes Games sind auch eine
Möglichkeit sich mit Soldatinnen und
Soldaten aus anderen Nationen
auszutauschen die Kriegserfahrung
verbindet sie alle
das ist bei der Veranstaltung um Krieg
und seine Folgen geht wird auf dem
Gelände immer wieder sichtbar die waren
inspiziert einen Transporthubschrauber
im November vergangenen Jahres würde ein
Donbass von einer russischen phosphorie
so schwer verletzt dass ihm beide Beine
amputiert werden müssen im Hubschrauber
fragen wie Ivan wie sich seine
Einstellung zum Krieg verändert hat
was ich darüber denke
nun ich denke dass ein Krieg wie in die
Russische Föderation gegen uns führt
immer einfach einen großen Schmerz und
eine noch größere Abscheu dagegen und
gegen den Feind hervorgerufen hat
der Krieg hat Ivans Leben verändert und
dass seine Familie seine Beine hat er im
Kampf verloren seine Lebenswillen aber
nicht
und jetzt schauen wir auf eine
Katastrophe deren Ausmaß auch drei Tage
später Hannah noch nicht wirklich
abzusehen ist nach dem verheerenden
Erdbeben in Marokko ist die Zahl der
Toten auf über 2800 gestiegen zudem wird
weiterhin fieberhaft nach Vermissten
unter den Trümmern gesucht und dabei zu
helfen sind inzwischen auch such und
Rettungsteams aus Spanien Großbritannien
Kata und den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten in Marokko eingetroffen
Einsatzkräfte aus anderen Ländern
akzeptiert die marokkanische Regierung
weiterhin nicht die EU-Kommission
kündigte unterdessen humanitäre Hilfe in
Höhe von einer Millionen Euro an
und dem heute journal Update gibt es
später ein Gespräch dazu mit dem Leiter
der internationalen Zusammenarbeit beim
Deutschen Roten Kreuz Christoph Jonen
nach heftigen Unwettern und
Überschwemmungen werden in Libyen viele
Todesopfer befürchtet von bis zu 2000
möglichen Toten sprach die international
nicht anerkannte Regionalregierung im
Osten des Landes zuvor war von 150
Todesopfern die Rede Berichte würden
darauf hindeuten dass Dutzende Dörfer
und Städte schwer von dem Sturm
getroffen wurden erklärte die
un-koordinatorin für humanitäre Hilfe in
Libyen mindestens eine Region wurde zum
Katastrophengebiet erklärt
der nordkoreanische Machthaber Kim Jong
unwirt in den kommenden Tagen zu einem
Besuch in Russland erwartet das haben
Moskau und Pjöngjang bestätigt die USA
vermuten das ist bei dem Treffen mit dem
russischen Präsidenten Putin um
Waffengeschäfte gehen wird beide Seiten
gaben keine Details zum genauen
Zeitpunkt des Besuchs bekannt
südkoreanische Medien hatten zuvor
berichtet dass Kim Pjöngjang bereits in
einem Zug verlassen habe
unter deutscher Leitung hat in der
Ostsee vor der Küste Lettlands und
Estlands heute das Großmanöver northern
coasts begonnen 3000 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten aus 14 Ländern Proben hier den
Bündnisfall zum manöververband gehören
rund 30 Schiffe und Boote Luftfahrzeuge
sowie diverse Landeinheiten geleitet
wird die rund zwei wöchige Übung von
Rostock aus
22 Jahre nach den Terroranschlägen vom
11 September wurde in den USA heute mit
zahlreichen Veranstaltungen der Opfer
gedacht bei einer Zeremonie in New York
Clasen Angehörige die Namen der rund
3000 Todesopfer vor der
Gedenkveranstaltung am Ground Zero nahm
auch
us-vizepräsidentin Harris Teil am 11
September 2001 hatten islamistische
Terroristen mehrere entführte Flugzeuge
in das World Trade Center in New York
und das Pentagon in Washington gesteuert
eine weitere Maschine stürzte in
Pennsylvania ab
nine eleven ein Tag der sich in das
Gedächtnis vieler Menschen weltweit
gebrannt hat ist nun 22 Jahre her in
Chile gedenkt man heute bereits zum 50
Mal einem 11 September
1973 das Militärputsch Menschen werden
gefoltert ermordet verschleppt der
Präsidentenpalast brennt und General
pinoce beginnt seine Diktatur gebaut auf
Leichen und Leid sie dauert ganze 17
Jahre lang der Putsch von damals spaltet
die chilenische Gesellschaft bis heute
auch weil die Narben noch sehr tief
sitzen weil viele Verbrechen nie
aufgeklärt worden sind das berichtet
jedenfalls Christopher hat
es ist ein kalter Wintertag in Santiago
de Chile Wilma montoia vor dem was von
ihrem Vater geblieben ist eine Zeile
raula verschwunden am 21.07 1976
einer von Tausenden die während der
Militärdiktatur verschleppt gefoltert
ermordet und irgendwo verscharrt wurden
ich komme hierher und spreche mit ihm
ganz privat ganz persönlich über die
kurze Zeit die wir zusammen hatten
vor genau 50 Jahren putschte
Armeegeneral Augusto Pinochet gegen die
demokratisch gewählte sozialistische
Regierung von Präsident Salvador Allende
unterstützt wurde er von westlichen
Regierungen allen voran den USA es
folgte eine blutige Militärdiktatur bis
1990 der tausende zum Opfer fielen
viele wurden mitten in der Stadt im
Nationalstadion eingesperrt gefoltert
und ermordet
das Stadion ist heute ein Ort des
Gedenkens zum Jahrestag treffen sich
Überlebende
doch letztendlich ist jeder mit seinem
Trauma allein
Gonzalo Lagos war 23 Jahre alt und in
der sozialistischen Studentenschaft
aktiv als er hier eingesperrt und
gefoltert wurde
ich habe Grausamkeiten gesehen tote wie
Menschen ermordet wurden ich war noch so
jung und musste all das erleben hier hat
man Dinge gesehen von denen man nicht
dachte dass Menschen in der Lage wären
so etwas zu tun
nein zur Straflosigkeit steht über den
Fotos der Opfer vor dem
Präsidentenpalast viele Schicksale sind
ungeklärt viele der Verantwortlichen
wurden nie zur Rechenschaft gezogen
zum Gedenktag marschiert der linke
Präsident Gabriel bodic gemeinsam mit
Angehörigen und kündigt eine
systematische aufarbeitungskampagne doch
das ist nicht ohne politisches Risiko
die offene Wunde der Diktatur spaltet
das Land auch die Anhänger pinojets
marschieren in diesen Tagen mehr als ein
Drittel der chilen sind die Diktatur
positiv am Rande des Gedenkens kommt es
zur Ausschreitungen
unsere Demokratie bleibt zerbrechlich
solange wir uns nicht der Vergangenheit
stellen sagt Wilma dazu sie zeigt uns
Fotos aus besseren Tagen eines der
letzten gemeinsam mit ihrem Vater einem
Gewerkschaftsführer bevor er verschleppt
wurde seitdem fehlt jede Spur von ihm
ich möchte wenigstens irgendetwas von
ihm haben irgendwas
ein kleines Stück von seinem Finger
vielleicht
solange ich das nicht habe
ich werde es irgendwo finden
gefangen in der Vergangenheit die Wilmer
und ganz Chile erst hinter sich lassen
können wenn es endlich Antworten gibt
und wir kommen erstmal zurück jetzt nach
Deutschland und wir schauen auf das
größte
Infrastrukturprojekt der Energiewende
das den schlichten Namen südling trägt
es war ein langer Anlauf denn so groß
wie das Vorhaben so groß war auch der
Streit und dadurch hat sich das ganze
Vorhaben auch um Jahre verzögert aber
heute ging es los mit Spatenstich und
allem Pipapo der Plan durch über 700 km
Leitung soll Strom von den Windparks im
Norden nach Süddeutschland transportiert
werden in fünf Jahren soll das ganze
dann tatsächlich fertiggestellt sein
allerdings sind bisher nur wenige
Kilometer der Trasse überhaupt genehmigt
Karl Hinterleitner und Henriette de
Maiziere
Bauteile für Autos Transformatoren und
die Elektroindustrie schon seit 77
Jahren produziert der mittelständische
Familienbetrieb war es noch im
fränkischen Forchheim angesichts der
rekordsteigerungen bei Energiepreisen
liegt der Chef besorgt in die Zukunft
momentan waren wir noch keine
energieintensives Unternehmen aber wir
merken das auch den Energiepreise werden
auf absehbare Zeit etwa beim 2-3-fachen
von dem liegen was in den Ländern
bezahlt werden muss unsere
Hauptwettbewerber sitzen das wird für
uns eine große Herausforderung sein von
hier könnte grüne und günstige Energie
kommen an der Nordseeküste produzieren
sie Windstrom für ganz Deutschland
theoretisch aber es fehlen Leitungen das
soll sich jetzt ändern baustärkte Süd
Interesse die den Strom nach Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg bringen Wort Robert
Habeck eigentlich ein wohlfühltermin für
den Minister schließlich Feier der einen
Erfolg doch habe ich meint es ging alles
noch nicht schnell genug
eigentlich hätte die südwindleitung der
gesamte Netzausbau den wir jetzt bereden
schon jetzt fertig sein sollen sie sehen
dass wir noch fünf sechs Jahre brauchen
ungefähr wir hängen also ganz schön
hinterher das sollte uns nicht wieder
passieren tatsächlich sind von 700 km in
südlingen ist 17 endgültig genehmigt und
Bürger vor Ort wären sich vehement gegen
die geplante stromautobahn um die
Proteste abzufedern plant man jetzt
unter statt überirdisch doch Erdkabel
sind teurer als Freileitungen und haben
eine deutlich längere Bauzeit in der Tat
haben wir das Problem ein Stück weit
verlagert der Hintergrund war ja dass
man erwartet hat mehr Akzeptanz zu
bekommen wenn wir mit diesen Kabeln
gehen wir sehen es ist deutlich teurer
geworden es ist technisch
anspruchsvoller so soll südlingen jetzt
10 Milliarden Euro kosten doch wenn die
Energiewende gelingen soll sein die
Ausgaben vertretbar meinen
Wirtschaftsexperten die Entscheidung
diese Kabel unterirdisch zu machen ist
wichtig ist zwar teurer aber es ist
wichtig um letztlich auch die soziale
Akzeptanz zu schaffen dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sagen ja wir
stimmen zu wir machen dort mit und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass man diese
Kosten diese höheren Kosten auch in Kauf
nimmt Michael Wagner interessieren vor
allem die Energiekosten für sein
Unternehmen noch sind die günstigen
Erneuerbaren nicht da und bis sie aus
dem Norden zu ihm nach Bayern kommen
wird er noch fünf Jahre warten müssen
2028 fertig sein
wenn es denn dann bei diesem Großprojekt
wirklich mal im Zeitplan bleibt also bei
5 Jahren mal schauen wir machen jetzt
jedenfalls weiter mit dir die
EU-Kommission geht in ihrer neuen
Konjunkturprognose davon aus dass die
Wirtschaft in der Europäischen Union in
diesem Jahr weniger wachsen wird als
bisher erwartet und einer der
Hauptgründe dafür ist Deutschland weil
realer warum genau weil Deutschland als
einzige große Volkswirtschaft dieses
Jahr voraussichtlich in eine Rezession
rutscht damit rechnet die EU-Kommission
und justiert deswegen auch nach unten
somit wird aus dem jahrelangen
Wachstumstreiber Europas nun eine Bremse
wobei auch die EU selbst nicht besonders
stark ist mit einem prognostizierten
Wachstum von 0,8% Deutschland hingegen
schrumpft um 0,4% am anderen Ende der
Skala Spanien mit einem erwarteten
Wachstum von
2,2%, die Prognosen aus Brüssel decken
sich weitgehend mit den Erwartungen
vieler Forschungsinstitute ebenso die
Begründung die Industrie fällt das
Wachstumsmotor aus weil sie unter den
hohen Energiepreisen und der Mount
Weltwirtschaft leidet und auch die
Inflation und die stark gestiegenen
Zinsen belasten die Wirtschaft was
erwartet die EU denn für das kommende
Jahr da soll es aufwärts gehen wenn auch
schleppend Lichtblick für Deutschland
bleibt der starke Arbeitsmarkt eine sehr
niedrige Erwerbslosigkeit und eine
abflachende Inflation was du mir bin
Konsum führen könnte dass Deutschland
wie in letzter Zeit häufiger kolportiert
wieder der kranke Mann Europas sei dass
sie die EU-Kommission nicht man wissen
dass das Land deine starke Wirtschaft
habe vielen Dank Valerie für deine
Einordnungen
der Schweizer Gotthard Straßentunnel ist
auf unbestimmte Zeit gesperrt worden
grund ist laut den Schweizer Behörden
ein etwas 25 m langer Riss in der Decke
des Tunnels Betonteile hätten sich
gelöst und sein auf die Fahrbahn
gefallen hieß es weiter die Ursache sei
bisher unklar zu Schaden gekommen sein
niemand der Gott hat Tunnel ist eine der
wichtigsten Verkehrsverbindungen durch
die Alpen im August wurde bereits die
Eisenbahnlinie für Reisende gesperrt
drei Wochen nach dem kuss-skandal hat
der Präsident des spanischen
Fußballverbands robialis seinen
Rücktritt eingereicht zudem legte er
seine vizepräsidentschaft der UEFA
niederbubiales war wegen übergriffigen
Verhaltens gegen die Spielerin Herr
mosso nach dem spanischen WM Sieg von
der FIFA 94 Tage gesperrt worden seit
dem Vorfall hatte es in Spanien Proteste
gegeben Weltmeisterin Herr Musso
erstattete Anzeige in seinem
Rücktrittsschreiben bezeichnete rubiales
die Reaktionen als Zitat maßlose
Kampagne
auf Hawaii ist der
vulkanea ausgebrochen und das bereits
zum dritten Mal in diesem Jahr der
Vulkan spuckt über 20 Meter hohe Lava
Fontänen Anwohner kamen bisher nicht so
Schaden aber weiß zweitgrößter Vulkan
liegt in einem Nationalpark auf Big
Island in sicherer Entfernung von
Menschen und Gebäuden die
Katastrophenschutzbehörde warte jedoch
sich vor austretendem Gas und Asche zu
schützen
und angeblich ist dieser Vulkan der
aktivste der Welt und wir gehen jetzt
aber in den passivzustand also in den
Feierabend
Gundula Gause bleibt aber noch ein
bisschen hier und wach und meldet sich
gegen Mitternacht mit unserem heute
journal Update das war es von uns machen
sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind bis
morgen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend mit dem Spätsommerwetter
geht es jetzt erstmal zu Ende da kommt
eine Kaltfront heran und bevor diese
keilfront wirklich zu uns aufzieht wird
es erstmal gewittrig das sehen sie ja in
dieser roten Linie die ersten Gewitter
kommen schon heute Nacht an und morgen
geht's dann gleich gewittrich weiter
heute Nacht also erwarten wir Gewitter
besonders in Nordrhein-Westfalen und den
Niedersachsen das können zum Teil
Unwetter sein also Gewitter die mit
Starkregen verbunden sind so 30 bis 50
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter sind
möglich im Osten und dem Süden ist das
dagegen klar und im Südosten bildet sich
zum Teil dichter Nebel die Temperaturen
singen auf 18 bis 12 Grad und liegen
morgen im Norden und im Nordwesten bei
22 bis 24 Grad sonst werden noch mal 25
bis 32 Grad erreicht Regenschauer und
Gewitter der Nacht erreichen morgen
Vormittag die Ostsee in der Mitte und
Süden ist es noch strahlend sonnig am
Nachmittag kommen die nächsten daran die
betreffen dann Rheinland-Pfalz
Nordrhein-Westfalen später dann auch
Niedersachsen und das können auch wieder
Unwetter sein kräftige Gewitter erwarten
wir auch aus den Alpen heraus oder zum
Beispiel im Schwarzwald Regenschauer und
Gewitter gibt es dann auch noch am
Mittwoch die erreichen dann den Osten am
Donnerstag beschränken sich die
Regenfälle und die Gewitter am Freitag
dann auf den Südosten dann wird es
deutlich kühler und wie sie hier am
Trend für Bremen sehen können liegen die
Temperaturen dann soweit 20 bis 25 Grad
es gibt aber noch mal einen Spätsommer
Nachschlag guten Abend